[Musik]
wenn es um das thema luftfahrt geht
stehen vor allem die piloten im
scheinwerferlicht
diese machen natürlich einen wichtigen
job aber ohne ein team aus technikern
flugbetriebs mitarbeitern aber auch
rettungskräften im hintergrund könnten
die flieger bei der airpower 19 nicht so
entspannt abheben
deshalb holen wir drei dieser vielen
unsichtbaren helden jetzt hinter dem
vorhang hervor
ich bin jürgen stark der fluglotse im
tower in zentren der aufgabe aus
prinzipiellen vermeiden von
zusammenstößen zwischen luftfahrzeugen
und gegenverkehr und natürlich zu den
sucht fahrzeugen untereinander und wir
versuchen das ganze so effizient und
schnell als möglich abzunehmen
[Applaus]
den fluglotsen mussten prinzip affinität
zu fliegerei und auch zur technik für
mich war fluglotse wo immer der
traumberuf von kindheit an
und der ist gut zu sein frage wurde
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das besondere an der bar für mich ist
auch die fülle an luftfahrzeugen und am
meisten freue ich mich wenn die show
sicher und gut über die bühne gegangen
ist
[Applaus]
ich bete ramisch mannheim und bin
flugzeugtechnik abrundete
man braucht fingerfertigkeit weil es ist
zwischenzeitlich schon relativ eng zum
arbeiten man trotz aller sportlichen
voraussetzungen sollten aufweisen das
war in die engen räume oder
räumlichkeiten hineinpasst
das schönste ist wenn wir alles
techniker mit laut matschiner sitzt als
elfter
das ist unglaublich unbeschreibliches
für das besondere für mich ist die
vielfalt der luftfahrzeuge april in die
geschichte ein blicken uns natürlich die
air show es ist an volker fried dass man
doch mitwirken kann
[Musik]
ich bin der kernreingewinn als leiter
des emergency response teams er hier
während der bauer 19 eingedämmt herz
versteht für merchants response team er
und ist ein bewegliches rettungs element
des was anders bezogen wie zb feuer bei
der airpower 19 gebildet wird und ja wir
sind für alles nachmittag etwas
unvorhersehbares passiert dass wir dort
die ersten rettungs und bergemaßnahmen
einleiten
bisher besteht aus 23 experten aus den
bereichen rettung und bergung aus dem
bereich der gefahrenabwehr im bereich
der sicherung wir haben einen heeres
bergführer dabei der wo sie als alpiner
berater dient und ein pressedienst die
für die öffentlichkeitsarbeit zuständig
sind
war der airport dabei zu sein das ist
ein mix aus nach vorfreude bei uns ein
tolles flugprogramm erwartet das was wir
hautnah miterleben dürfen
und natürlich gewisse anspannung weil
man eigentlich immer bereit sein müssen
etwas unvorhersehbares passiert dass wir
pleite und bergemaßnahmen durchmisst
[Musik]